بما يزيد على اثني عشر ساعه احيانا وهذا
طبعا بسبب الظروف الجويه السيئه بسبب
الظروف المناخيه لكن نحن مع كل
الزملاء ومع كل فرقنا نحن انتقلنا الى هنا
الساعه 8:30 صباحا يوم الزلزال ومنذ ذلك
الوقت نحن في مركز التنسيق وفي الساحه مع
كل زملائنا نسعى استكمال النقائص واستنقاذ
مواطنين من تحت الانقاضي
وايضا
هذه الكارثه
المنتشره في مرعشواء غيرها نبذل جهودا
كبيره لمكافحه اضرار هذا الزجاج نحن هنا
نحتاج الى لغه بنائه
هناك حاجه لتضامن الجميع وعلى جميع ان
يشدوا سواعدهم نحن في حاجه الى شمول
والتكامل لاننا الامر الذي نواجهه وان كان
صغيرا او كبيرا
هذا
متعلق بحياه الانسان واي موضوع يدخل بشان
حياه انسان فهو موضوع في غايه الاهميه
وبالتالي في محافظه مرعش هدم تسعه واحد
واربعين مبنى بحصيله اوليه ويتوقع ان
الرقم اعلى من ذلك وحتى الان 600 شخص
من هذه المحافظه دفناهم
وخلال اعمال الدفن اداره النيابه العامه
والافتاء ومديريات الامن
الادارات المحليه
والاجهزه الطبيه
قمنا بهذه الاعمال ونقوم بها بتنسيق تام
من بين هذه المؤسسات كلها بالتعرف على
هويات
الموتى ضحايا الزلزال باخذ البصمات
والتعرف عليهم من قبل اقاربهم ولا زنا
نستكمل هذه الاجراءات وفي هذا الاطار ايضا
من سواء على الصعيد الداخلي
العالمي هناك ما يزيد على 2000
و96 فريق بحث وانقاذ طبعا نحن اذا صورنا
ان هناك تسعه واحد واربعين مبنى هدم
بالكامل وان هناك 2000 فريق عامل نحن هذا
يوضح بشكل جلي ايضا
وبما يقتضي ان نوضح الشعب بناء نتسابق مع
زمن لانه في بعض اماكن
كوارث هناك بحث فرق بحث وانقاذ تعمل لمده
10 ساعات وعشرين ساعه واكثر من ذلك ومستمر
كل الاعمال
وعلى صعيد المدن التابعه للمحافظه مدينه
في الثاني الثاني عشر شباط بازار
هذه المدن الى كل هذه المدن نحاول ان نصل
الى كل هذه المدن طبعا ما يفرقنا عن
المحافظات الاخرى اننا في الوقت نفسه
كنا مركزه زلزال الثاني ايضا الذي كان
بقوه 7.6 في
البيسون
ولاسيما في الجنوبي من المحافظه
ليس هناك اي الاتراك
الاول
لكن نحن بعد الزلزال الثاني واجهنا زلزال
الثاني ايضا وبالتالي
ذلك الجانب الشمالي من المحافظه ايضا في
البستان في الوقت نفسه هناك هطول ثلج كثيف
والظروف مناخيه صعبه
يجب ان نركز على البستان بشكل اكبر ونحن
نقوم بذلك بالفعل نوجه الفرق القادمه الى
هنا الى تلك المنطقه
وحتى الان وخصوصا في محافظه مرعش
وجهنا 11 الف خيمه ما يزيد على 5000 منها
تم انشاؤه واكثر من ذلك خلال حتى هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي وهنا معلومه اود ان
اشارككها واياهم واياكم هنا قوات الجندرما
الشرطه وجنودنا البواسل
تام يعملون لحفظ امن المواطنين اولا
لمسانده البحث والانقاذ
والتحقيق الدعم اللوجستي للفرقه الاخرى
ثالثا
ايضا تاسيس وانشاء الخيم هم يعملون في
تكاتف تام ويبدلون كل جهودهم في هذا
الاطار حتى الان في عموميه التركيه هناك
ثمانيه عشره الف دركي عامل في
وما يقارب عشره الاف شرطي والان اصدرنا
تعليمات لتجديد وتوجيهي وتوظيف احد عشر
الاف الدركي اخر ونكمل ايضا توظيف وتوجيه
افراد الشرطه للعمل في منطقه الكوارث اود
التوضيحه هنا هو ان الدوله
تستغل كل امكاناتها وتبذل كل امكاناتها
بشكل
يتواجه هذه الكارثه التي ليس لها سابق من
حيث ظروفها من حيث شده الزلزال وتوزعها
على مناطق عده
وايضا الى جانب هذا كله
اود ان اوضح هذه النقطه بشكل خاص
لكي لا يبقى احد من مواطنين
وحده وحيدا
ان لا يبقى مواطننا على انفراد وتحقيق
التنسيق التامي ايضا بالتوفيق الامن حتى
الان تم تعيين وتوظيف 31 والي محافظ
واحد وسبعين
قائم مقام متصرف اداري في هذه الاداره كما
تم توظيف وتوجيه العديد من المؤسسات في
المحافظات المجاوره
وتم سحب
الموظفين والعاملين في ادارات في
المحافظات المجاوره الى هذه المنطقه
نواجه هذه الكارثه التي تركت فينا جروحا
غائره
هنا نقطه اود ان اوضحها مع تمنياتي
وبعض النواقص
هنا في هذه الطاوله احيانا نكون في ظرف
يقتضي منها ان نواجه 100 مساله مختلفه في
ان واحد ونحن نواجه هذه المشكله طبعا
مواطنين الذين هم في الساحه يعيشون مشاكل
اكبر بكثير
لانهم يواجهون اذا مشاهدينا سنكتفي بهذا
القدر من هذه الكلمه لوزير الداخليه
التركيه يتحدث فيها عن عمليات الانقاذ